i think what your viewers have to
understand is that every
winter
a number of some energy suppliers
exit the market they leave because
they can't uh maintain their financial
position this year the wholesale prices
are going up very high
so the price at which they get
gas
is much higher
and of course that puts more pressure on
them and that's why a number of these
companies are saying that we should some
of them are saying we should lift the
price cap some of them are saying that
we should perhaps bail them out
and i've been very focused on three
principles i think firstly we've got to
look after customers we've got to make
sure there's a continuity of supply and
we've got to look after the most
vulnerable and particularly elderly
customers that's my first priority the
second thing i've said is that i don't
think
we should be uh throwing taxpayers money
at companies which have been let's face
it badly run a number of these companies
have been badly run as i say every year
between five and eight companies exit
the market and i don't want to prop up
uh failing companies i don't want to
there to be a reward for failure i don't
think the taxpayer should be propping
those up and then the third principle is
that
as you said in your
header the energy price cap is here to
stay i don't want to uh remove that i
don't want to go back to the old days
where very very small number of
companies were essentially
pushing up prices and
extorting lots of value from from
customers who had no choice problem is
that price cup policies can't cope with
extremes can they that's that's the main
issue and it's a mistaken intervention
some would say by a conservative
government to to cap prices yeah that is
an argument but what we had before only
a few years ago
was a market where you had very small
number of uh
companies
that were charging very very high prices
and that's why we brought in the price
cap but what the price cap has done has
actually forced uh companies to innovate
they've been lots of new entrants as
we've seen
and now we're at a point where some of
those new entrants are feeling the
pressure and some of them uh it may well
be have have not been managed properly
state back loans is an option
there are lots of options i mean
currently at the moment uh it's
important people understand this we have
mechanisms in place so there's a thing
called solar which stands for the
supplier of last resort which means that
if your energy company goes past uh the
customers from that company will go
to another company which can absorb the
number of customers these these
structures already there the issue this
year as you know is that there may be
more than the usual five to eight
it won't be a house of cards but there
should be there'll be more than five to
eight uh there could be more than five
to eight it's not happened yet there
could be more than five to eight at the
usual companies that he does that exit
uh and we have to have a much more
robust
uh supply of last resort uh how many are
you sure before what's your worst case
scenario on the number of companies i'm
not going to put a number on that um as
i say most years i mean i've been energy
minister for this my third year third
winter uh five to eight is is generally
uh what what we've observed
and it could be it could be worse than
that but i i can't tell you the exact
number so what's gonna happen to all of
those customers the customers and this
is my first principle
we'll have a complete continuity of
supplies so we will find energy
suppliers there will be energy suppliers
for those customers and that's what the
supplier of last resort the the
mechanism we already have in place
that's what it means which is why you
need to look um to state back loans for
some of those bigger companies to
support and those who are taking on
extra customers yeah those are some of
the ideas that are discussed you're
quite right because it costs a company
to absorb
up to hundreds of thousands of customers
from another company that's failed that
that costs money and there may well be
a provision for some sort of loan uh and
that's been discussed that's been widely
reported okay so when will you make
decisions on that i'm speaking to small
uh suppliers today i spent the whole
weekend speaking to the regulator i
spoke to larger suppliers
and we're getting around a roundtable of
smaller suppliers
and we want to get a full range of
market opinion how have we found
ourselves in this position i think that
there have been
extreme uh
the volatile commodity prices last year
we saw the oil price was at twenty
dollars one one uh in april roughly and
then it went up to eighty and it's come
back down a bit uh with gas prices this
year we've had obviously the kovid
pandemic huge demand coming out of asia
and that spiked the price
uh and that's one of the things one of
the features of the post-covered
recovery yeah what about um worst case
scenarios you said yesterday in the
house of commons that it was alarmist to
say that people would struggle to heat
their homes in the winter months yeah so
my uh thinking behind that the reason
i've said that
is that there are two issues here the
gas prices
and then of course there's the security
of supply the idea that somehow we won't
be able to get enough of the stuff
what i was trying to say yesterday and
what i said yesterday was that
security of supply is not an issue we've
got lots of diverse
sources of gas
the structure of the market in terms of
the energy suppliers that is an issue
and that's what we've been talking about
will you say that people um won't um
struggle to heat their homes in the
winter months but of course they do
already
um
they
the issue i was saying
well yeah in terms of costs but i'm just
saying that there is constant continuity
of supply that was what i i was focusing
on we're mixing up two things here not
really because the bottom line is you
can either heat your home or you can't
no the the reasons why you can either
heat it because it costs a lot of money
or you can you or you you can't heat it
because there simply isn't enough gas
and one of the concerns that was
expressed yesterday was that we would
simply wouldn't have
enough of the gas we wouldn't have
enough of the stuff uh to be able to
heat our homes and that was the
mis impression that was the the the myth
if you like i was trying to bust
yesterday yeah but the reason that
people can't hit their homes is because
they can't afford the gas yes and
obviously gas prices are going to go up
aren't they you'll say that there's a
price cap but hundreds of thousands of
people are about to come off their fixed
term tariffs and their prices are going
to go up so the price cap as you know
has uh really kept prices down
for hundreds of thousands if not
millions of customers
the gas companies are saying the energy
companies are saying they want to lift
the price cap because they want to raise
prices but i've said that we're keeping
the price cap yeah but my point is that
people are coming off the fixed term
tariffs and as a result their prices
could go up up to did i read something
like 1500 pounds more no i don't i don't
reckon so what figures do you recognize
so i think that uh what will happen uh
and we've got to wait and see what
happens to the market we've got to wait
and see what happens uh to the suppliers
uh but i've said because of the cap and
also in terms of uh trying to limit uh
rises uh we shouldn't be uh in a
situation where people are paying uh
the amount that you said so what is the
worst case scenario for people who are
coming off those fixed term tariffs i
think that people
should be able to find
a pricing which is very much in line
with their old
uh with their on their old tariff but as
you say we've got to wait and see
how many of the suppliers are affected
clearly there's a world of difference if
as you you is usually the case five to
eight suppliers uh exit the market leave
or if it's if it's more than that and
the figures in the ft yesterday saying
you know there could be dozens you don't
you don't recognize i don't recognize
that i mean i've just in terms of
background when i became an energy
minister more than two years ago there
were 65 suppliers
today the figure i think is about 55.
i'm going to need to check that because
obviously
yeah it fluctuates um do i think that
they'll be fit there has to be am i
going to bail out all 55 of those
companies if in an extreme case no i
don't think we can do that because some
of those companies a handful of them
probably would have exited anyway so i
don't see why
what's the criteria for bailing them out
well they've got to look at we've got to
look at their financial position uh some
of these companies probably would have
exited anyway and there's no point so
some of these businesses are just
chances that they like it when it's um a
sunny day and when actually they find
themselves in a position where they're
not making money because of the price
cap then they come cap in hand to the
government is that what that sometimes
happens i mean that's one of the reasons
why as i said every year that i've been
in the job five to eight companies have
exited the market for various reasons
and the conservative government is not
going to build businesses i don't think
it makes any sense to put taxpayers
money your money our money to companies
that have been badly run
are you going to bail out this business
that
makes carbon dioxide for the food
industry but has had to close because
it's just not financially viable at the
moment we're definitely looking at
trying to secure
carbon dioxide
uh supply
uh and it's what is that at night
well i think i think we're getting that
i mean i spoke to the chancellor
yesterday
uh spoken to the the ceo of the business
an american man cf industries uh yep
tony will spoken to him twice he flew
over
uh on sunday i spoke to him on sunday
lunchtime we didn't have a lunch but we
spoke very candidly about the situation
of his company how did that conversation
go it was a it was a frank conversation
he said that the problem he had was that
the natural gas price is much higher
than the ammonia which he sells so
essentially what happened last week was
that the the the plant down tools
and i said of course we've got to
manufacture this uh
co2 and that's what we're we're talking
about this week
so we don't have much time as far as
that's concerned it's pretty imminent
but uh i'm confident today tomorrow in
the next
three this week i hope uh we we have a
very clear plan
to to get the co2 production going i
mean that's a pretty big deal if he's
flying over to have a chat especially
given how challenging it is to fly at
the moment so did you get him to come so
you could talk to him i didn't oh he
wanted to uh come and see
us see me in government i went to the
office we had a very good conversation
about the situation and we're determined
to but you made it clear that we can't
not have these factories open
that's a a very clear steer that i gave
him okay and you think by the end of the
week we'll have that sorted out i am
very confident and hopeful that we can
sort it out in the week isn't it
somewhat frustrating that we find
ourselves in a position where we're
being held um to ransom by a business
like this how could we find ourselves in
that position why don't we see it coming
we uh have lots of contingency plans
um
the the gas uh distribution is very wide
but in this particular instance the
manufacturer of co2
was critically dependent on natural gas
where you've got skyrocketing rocketing
prices
what we've done is we've looked at how
we can get the production going again
and i'm hopeful confident that we'll be
able to do that because it is time
critical as you point out i was reading
just yesterday that pig farmers
i've got all these pigs that need to go
to market chicken farmers as well and if
they're not done by the end of the week
they have to slaughter all these animals
and put them in landfills you're
absolutely right and that's one of why
the carbon dioxide situation is critical
and that's why i spent all of you what
are we going to do about that going
forward to make sure that we're not
finding ourselves in that position in
future i think we have to have a
diversity of sources of uh carbon
dioxide
cff isn't the only company
that manufactures uh carbon dioxide why
are we so reliant on them um they have a
big show of the market i said they
weren't the only one but they are
they're a big part of the carbon dioxide
market
and as far as our gas supply is
concerned how concerned are we that the
russians are basically controlling how
much gas we get and don't get i think
the levels are down to 20 of
pre-pandemic levels i don't
think that there's much concern as far
as we're concerned
from where we get our gas very little of
our
gas comes from russia
50 of it is sourced here in the uk and
30
that comes from norway and i spoke to
the norwegian energy minister yesterday
and she was very confident
that that supplier from norway
was was secure they've also said in a
way that they're going to increase
production so they're going to increase
capacity of next week
to make sure that we we get the gas we
need we're very reliable on the reliant
i should say on the spot market though
we don't seem to have the storage
capability that we had previously i
think there was a place in the north sea
where it closed in 2017 was it 2017
2017. yeah and we don't have that big
storage facility anymore which means
that we are very susceptible to the
ranges in price yeah we i mean it's
you've got to remember okay it's a globe
i look at these things all the time it's
a global price spike so every country uh
certainly in europe particularly about
storage should we be looking at the
orange
i i completely uh understand it but i'm
just trying to put a context no i
understand um this spike is completely
unprecedented we've had a global
pandemic there's a huge uptick in demand
and everyone is trying to get the same
sources of gas and that's what's caused
the spike now i think in this situation
you're right we need to look at our
energy strategy going forward i think
it's been fairly resilient if you look
at renewables if you look at the range
of sources of electricity it's pretty
wide much wider than a number of other
countries and that's something that is a
credit to the uk one of the other
options i suppose to keep people's gas
bills under control or fuel bills is to
pause the green levy is that something
you might think about no i haven't i
mean you'll appreciate it'll say that
that's an issue for the the chancellor
because it's a it's a fiscal tax yeah
but you can actually speak to him yeah i
do speak to you a lot um but i think the
green that we love is pretty much in its
infancy and actually we've been very
successful at moving away from fossil
fuels uh to renewables uh renewable
sources of power and that's that's a
british success story i don't know if
you ever we have a climate show here on
sky news that we we run i've been on it
a couple of times yeah for six every
evening we have sort of like a
projection of how much fuel is being
used every single day and every single
minute
at the moment we're using a lot of
fossil fuels that makes the price um a
bit more concerning doesn't it just
looking at it actually as we see 57
that's significantly higher than what it
normally is yeah that's the in terms of
gas you'll know that in that the coal
figure has gone down uh hugely so even
just eight years ago we had 40 percent
was from coal burning essentially and
that today that's about two percent so
we've done a a good job in moving away
from coal but you're right the natural
gas is still a big part of the of the
energy supply okay not something that we
can worry about just at the moment we
need to try and make sure that we get
the supply as best we can i want if i
can talk to you about this mod data
breach before i let you go what can you
tell us about this data breach regarding
afghan interpreters that is very
concerning it's very concerning and as
far as i know uh the well i do know the
secretary of state for defense has
launched an inquiry into this um clearly
that's something that is
deeply worrying i think it will cause a
lot of concern certainly with allies and
interpreters and friends in afghanistan
and i hope we can get to the bottom of
them that's all i can say about this
okay are you worried that lives could be
at risk as a result well look i think
it's uh
very difficult uh when people have you
know data is breached and people know
what others have been doing
but let's get to the bottom of the
investigation so that's a yes really
i just want to say that uh i think it's
a serious situation just before i let
you go i just reassure my viewers if you
would this morning i mean you're very
you you sat in a relaxed fashion you're
very calm um very
leveled voice but a lot of people will
be worried about heating their homes and
putting food on the table over the next
few weeks i think
the next few days are going to be quite
challenging
but i'm very confident so critical and
then stopped no no i said they're quite
challenging um don't put words into my
life no i'm asking you it was
interesting but but you know i've been
in post i've been energy minister for
two years now i've been secretary of
state now for nearly a year i've spoken
to all many of the major players i've
spoken to the regulator and i'm very
confident that we'll be able to get
through this
and we'll look back
and say that we did a good job in terms
of getting through what was a global
situation it was a difficult global
situation and i think in the uk
we'll be able to navigate our way
through it and what can we do as um and
end of the line users what can we do to
try to help in the meantime i think
people need to look at their gas prices
and they need to look at
what what else is out there
potentially in the market i think people
need to be aware that there are lots and
lots of suppliers
and they are varying quality like in any
market where you've got 50 or 60
different suppliers they're not all uh
up to the same level some of them are
well capitalized well run others
less so and i think consumers probably
need to take a little bit more of an
active interest i don't think we should
you know try and all the gas experts but
just in terms of energy bills just to
see what what's out there
um is this the biggest challenge you
faced in your face the number of uh yeah
in your two years this this year there
was a
an energy blackout
um two weeks into the job
uh and commuters will remember i think a
million commuters were essentially
blacked out there was no electricity the
trains weren't moving that was in august
2019.
we had a whole issue with fracking uh
and you know 2.9 on the richter scale so
is it in an energy how does this compare
this is this is very serious and also it
has it's it's got a global uh dimension
to it in a way that some of those other
crises didn't but it's you know it's
it's it's a very volatile market there's
a lot going on in the global economy you
mentioned russia there's geopolitics
there's so many different uh uh strands
so many different forces acting on this
market and and it's a challenging and
simulating job that i do